the country has never fulfilled its
Promises of Freedom liberty and justice
for all it's always been Freedom liberty
and justice for something usually that
sum is uh white people our worst
hypocrisies
are our best evidence that we have
ideals at all you take a look at other
countries nobody ever calls the Chinese
Communist Party a hypocrite or China
hypocrite or Iran a hypocrite why is
that because to be a hypocrite you at
least had to have ideals in the first
place and so we're imperfect but we are
about the pursuit of a more perfect
union The Pursuit of Happiness America
is about the pursuit and so I think the
trashing ourselves I think we are
actually because you know we never were
included in those ideals originally
originally yeah but never enough
originally are two different things
originally that's true over 250 years of
progress if you had somebody who was in
1870 looking at the world we live in
today if you had somebody in 1960 who
was looking at the world we live in
today as it relates to race in America
we would be darn close to what they
would have thought of as the Promised
Land